nous avons mis en place des politiques strictes si
quelqu'un dans ce théâtre commet un acte de
violence à tout moment pendant le spectacle,
vous recevrez l'Oscar du meilleur
acteur
et serez autorisé à prononcer un discours de 19 minutes
si quelque chose d'imprévisible ou de
violent se produit pendant la cérémonie.
faites simplement ce que vous avez fait l'année dernière, ne restez pas
là et ne faites absolument rien,
peut-être même faites un câlin à l'agresseur
et si l'un d'entre vous se met en colère contre une blague et
décide de venir ici et de se
déchaîner, ce ne sera pas facile
ou quelques-uns de mes amis vont devoir s'en
sortir en premier, tu vas devoir
passer par le champion des poids lourds
Adonis Creed avant de m'atteindre
la bataille avec Michelle Eel avant de
m'atteindre après avoir battu le Mandalorien
avant toi  viens à moi, nous allons devoir
emmêler Tangle Fighter Man,
tu allais devoir t'embrouiller avec Fable
Man et ensuite tu vas devoir passer
par mon bras droit Guillermo l'
autre Guillermo non pas ça pas Del
Toro le oui celui-là